ja meine Damen und Herren ich wünsche
euch einen wunderschönen Sonntag
wir waren gestern Abend feiern in Köln
tatsächlich
und so wie ich jetzt gerade gesehen habe
ging das ganze nicht so gut zu Ende ein
paar Sachen ignorieren nein das wird
nicht ignoriert Digger was was wird hier
sauber gemacht warum triffst du so ja
ich habe gerade mein Handy gewaschen ja
dann trocknet die doch an Alter
ja hier sehen Sie zwei Mülltonnen ihr
fragt euch vermutlich Mensch Luca was
geht ab warum filmst du warum blockst du
einfach so ihr seht hier oben in der
Ecke bei the way Werbevideo eingeblendet
weil das ganze Video hier heute
Kooperation mit Lieferando
entsteht und ich werde heute essen
ausliefern also seid gespannt
Fabio ist übrigens ein Kollege von mir
aus der Heimat aus stabile Feld
das ist so
oh sorry Bruder ich wusste dass am
chillen willst ich bin ganz ehrlich
viele Leute aber oh mein Gott ich habe
mich gerade voll erschaffen falls du
Zuschauer hier gerade läuft auf meinem
Kanal und dir denkst ey ich gucke jetzt
mal laserluca seine Blogs die Stars es
wird nicht viel passieren
weiß nicht was wir daraus tendenziell so
erwarten sollen aber ich habe irgendwie
dreimal FIFA 23 gekauft
[Musik]
ist
ich gehe jetzt mal in die City bisschen
was essen
[Musik]
Mann danke übrigens dass mein letztes
Youtube-Video also das was ich
vorgestern hochgeladen habe in dem es
darum ging wie es weitergeht auf meinem
Kanal wie es mit mir weitergeht wie es
mit Peyton weiter geht die Trennung etc
danke dass das Platz 1 in den deutschen
Youtube Trends einfach ist das ist
irgendwie beängstigend no joke ich kann
nur realtalk nicht in Worte fast so was
mit der ganzen Support vielleicht
bedeutet und es gibt mir unfassbar viel
Kraft einfach in der letzten Zeit ich
weiß dass ich mir das in diesem Block
bisher nicht habe anmerken lassen und
ich habe einfach meine dummen jokes
gemacht und so und ich will auch nicht
mein Lachen verlieren in der Hinsicht es
geht halt einfach gerade viel ab in
meinem Leben aber solche dummen Momente
mit Freunden und auch die geile Korb
gleich ja lenkt mich so ein bisschen
auch ab und ihr steht bei the way gerade
auf meinem Saunaofen einfach nicht
funktioniert WoW und die Sonne ist
gerade tendenziell doch eher ein Bilder
Lagerplatz von der Wohnung kommt bei the
way erst in einiger Zeit also das dauert
auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Monate weil
die Wohnung halt bei weitem noch nicht
fertig ist noch ganz viele Restarbeiten
allerdings
gehe ich jetzt duschen und fahre dann zu
Lieferando eine Stunde später ich bin
bei Lieferando angekommen
ich kam mir gerade an habe schon so eine
kleine Sicherheitseinweisung bekommen
weil man halt mit so krankenfahrrädern
rumfährt Bruder das ist einfach E-Bikes
hey ihr wisst ich liebe Fahrradfahren
und auch noch mit dem E-Bike gleich
durch Köln das ist wunderschönes Wetter
ist es richtig aber Jacke die ich noch
richtig brutal finde ich schon gesagt
ich will auf jeden Fall eine für zu
Hause haben ja und ich bin jetzt hier im
Lieferando hab Köln das ist echt irre
hier sind die ganzen Rucksäcke die ganze
Sachen hier sind auch geile Graffiti
paintings an der Wand so ein bisschen
Ehrenfeld zeigen hier vorne stehen
überall Fahrräder Ausrüstung Helme da
unten geht's auch noch runter hier sind
auch noch Fahrräder aber ich werde jetzt
essen ausliefern und bekomme gleich eine
random Bestellung zugeteilt die haben
alle schon so ein bisschen gelacht also
ich weiß nicht wahrscheinlich muss ich
irgendwie 20 km weit fahren jetzt gerade
rein von Kitty Chai Köln Ehrenstraße und
ich habe jetzt tatsächlich auch gerade
erfahren warum die gerade alle so ein
bisschen gelacht haben als mir gesagt
haben das gleich eine random zufällige
Bestellung kommt denn die Bestellung
kommt von Sandra mit der war ich gestern
noch feiern und die hatte jetzt
anscheinend Hunger und hat sich
irgendwie mit Lieferando zusammengesetzt
hat gesagt komm ich bestellt was Luca
sollen wir das mal bringen
los geht's
das vor mir ist übrigens Siggi der
arbeitet auch bei Lieferando als Rider
und begleitet mich heute so ein bisschen
und zeigt mir das alles
ich will dieses Fahrrad behalten no joke
ich will auch diese Jacke behalten die
ist so wild die hält so warm und die
sieht echt krass nice aus ey ich weiß
ist der Korb hier steht Werbevideo aber
für diese Sachen werde ich nicht bezahlt
ich gerade sage ich werde diese Jacke
den einfach abkaufen das habe ich den zu
Beginn gerade schon gesagt aber gut ich
habe ein bisschen Angst bei meiner
Kamerahalterung hier auf dem Lenker
deswegen fühle mich jetzt erst wieder
wenn wir beim Restaurant angekommen sind
wir sind jetzt gerade bei Kitty Channel
Ehrenstraße angekommen no joke richtig
geiler Laden ähm ich will jetzt nicht
rumführen weil ich nicht weiß ob die das
wollen aber unsere Bestellung Liebe
bestellt haben ist schon fertig und wir
bringen dir zusammenrat Essen kommt in
den Rucksack schön hier alles isoliert
natürlich Rucksack jetzt ordnungsgemäß
verschlossen und wir schwarz
Sandra ich hoffe du hast Hunger hier ist
Liebe Ranzo ich habe viele Bestellung
für Sie hier
danke schön
lachkick hey es ist so nice ne ich habe
mich gerade hier mit Siggi das sind
tauchen Mitarbeiter von Lieferando alles
erklärt ja ja aber der ist verlobt ein
Auge Trinkgeld ne danke schön
danke
tschüss Ciao ihr kennt sie aus den
anderen Videos die ich hier schon mal
bei Sandra gedreht habe und auch vor
allem bei ihrem Treppenhaus das ist
nicht so ganz hoch ist die Decken aber
jetzt habe ich zum Glück mit dem
Lieferando Helm nicht mehr das Problem
dass ich danach immer Gehirn verliere
wenn ich es anders Wohnung verlasse
oh mein Gott ich bin gerade einfach drei
Treppenstufen runtergeschlittert weil
meine Schuhe nass sind die erste
Bestellung für den heutigen Tag ist
ausgeliefert meine lieben Freunde boah
diese echt sorry für das Fackeln ich
habe extra so eine
Kamerahalterung hier gekauft aber
irgendwie funktioniert nicht so gut die
erste Bestellung
macht auf jeden Fall ausgeliefert ich
werde jetzt noch ein paar andere
Bestellungen ausliefern vielleicht sogar
an den ein oder anderen von euch das
werde ich jedoch nicht filmen und äh
würde sagen dass wir uns dementsprechend
einfach dann in ein zwei Stunden am
Lieferando habe wiedersehen
ich könnte Kohle weitermachen so ich bin
zurück im Lieferando habe hier in Köln
angekommen ich werde jetzt meine Uniform
hier wegpacken den Helm wegpacken ich
werde ja einfach alles wegpacken außer
die Jacke weil die werde ich definitiv
behalten ich habe gerade noch zwei
weitere Bestellungen ausgeliefert es ist
unfassbar nice finde ich dass man halt
einfach mit so Leuten in Kontakt ist bei
diesem Beruf weil das habe ich auch ein
Podcast schon immer gesagt dass mir das
persönlich extrem wichtig wäre bei dem
Beruf dass ich nicht den ganzen Tag am
PC sitze sondern wirklich mit Menschen
interagiere was ich auch hier über das
Youtube Video mit euch quasi die ganze
Zeit nur und was mir auch aufgefallen
ist man entdeckt so viele neue Orte in
der Stadt wenn man die ganze Zeit
unterwegs ist und gerade für meine
storchenbeine ist es auch ein ziemlich
Workout obwohl man ein Fahrrad hat aber
ich habe auch manchmal diesen Modus
ausgeschaltet dass ich bisschen treten
musste naja gut ich gehe jetzt auf jeden
Fall nach Hause dann Fabio wartet auf
mich ich bin wieder zu Hause es war
wirklich sehr sehr ereignisreich das
ganze einfach mal zu sehen und zu
noch genauso wie vorher was machst du
gleich geht einfach die Sonne schon und
ich hasse so Motorrad sonst ne
[Musik]
einfach so ich finde das so crazy
ohne mich okay
gelernt der einfach die ganze Zeit
irgendwas mit
ident irgendwas
super sale gesagt und ich dachte jetzt
supercell gesagt und ich dachte der kann
mir irgendwie für Clash Royale clash of
Clans irgendwie so kostenlose points
klettern dann haben wir uns die ganze
Zeit so voll gut mit dem verstanden voll
gut gemacht der war ja 50 oder so
einfach so random alleine im Fluss sich
nicht Mitte 40 aber er war auch schon da
muss man sagen fünf Flaschen Champagner
für uns alle und so und das hat alles in
ergeben dass er bei supercell arbeitet
Blabla aber der meinte im Endeffekt
super sale er macht Laufkleidung aber
auch zu einem Jahr gesagt kommst du aus
Finnland ja gleich auf jeden Fall ein
Zug zurück nach Hause in die Heimat nach
stabilefeld auf jeden Fall würde ich den
Blog denke ich an der Stelle jetzt auch
einfach beenden weil Fabio fährt jetzt
die Sonne geht gleich unter und dann
gehe ich einfach schlafen weil ich
letzte Nacht nicht so viel geschlafen
habe danke anlieferando für die Ultra
nice Coop heute und für den
ereignisreichen Tag und dass ich das
einfach mal erleben durfte wie viel
Flexibilität und Freiheit man einfach
als Lieferando Fahrer hat Mario
eine umfassende Versicherung eine
unbefristete Direkteinstellung ein
garantierter basislohn ein zusätzlicher
Bonus ab der 26 Bestellung des Monats
und ein Trinkgeld welches sofort in der
kurier-app angezeigt wird und das hat
jetzt durch das ganze belgische Pflege
gehört ja aber muss man sagen bist du
auch mal spendabel also Lieferando top
Daumen hoch zum chillen
ich hoffe euch hat das Video gefallen
das war so ein richtig dummer stumpfer
Vlog oh ich finde sowas immer so süß sie
haben einfach irgendwelche Kinder
irgendwas mit dem Flohmarkt drauf
geschrieben aber egal